Lauren bobert the radical and repugnant
sanctimonious Republican congresswoman
who talks about how Christianity is the
one moral path and Christianity needs to
be involved in civil government and all
these different how everybody else is a
bad parent if they have a a trans kid or
if they're gay or whatever okay that
Lauren bober
was potentially involved in covering up
her own then husband soon to be
ex-husbands alleged
child abuse
against one of her own kids now whatever
the truth is about whatever abuse
one of Lauren bobert's Sons may have
suffered it's a law enforcement matter
but to the extent that these folks want
to make law and tell everybody else
what's right and what's wrong they are
horrible sanctimonious hypocrites